[Music]
these sessions are mandatory for all
staff sister anne
my mother struggled with depression
annie annie honey can i come in
but even as a child i knew it was danny
open the door please
more
[Music]
my mother talked about hearing that
voice inside
she said the voice didn't really want
her
it wanted me
the citadel has fallen black smoke
blocks out the sun because as some of
you may already know
we have a female student in a class only
as an observer so let's descend into the
mouth of hell shall we
there are more possessions reported
today than at any other time in history
certainly must fight for every soul
[Music]
defend us in battle against the spirits
of wickedness
[Music]
i believe the demon that is tormenting
natalie and the demon that possessed my
mother are one in the same
i'd like to teach sister just enough to
protect herself and others
this relationship she has
it's personal
we've been waiting for you
[Music]
your mother has a pretty voice
hello
be careful
once you know the devil
the devil knows you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]